Change is blowing in China...
...in the form of green technologies like these wind turbines.
For each of the last four years,...
...China has doubled its wind energy capacity.
In this year, the People's Republic is set to overtake the US...
...as the world's top manufacturer of wind turbines.
Generally speaking, I think China's wind power business is booming.
In the next decade, China believes it can match Europe...
...by producing a fifth of its energy needs from renewable sources.
China is striving to become a clean energy superpower...
...even as the United States moves to do the same.
There's no longer a question about whether the jobs and industries of the 21st century will be...
...centered around clean, renewable energy.
The only question is which country will create these jobs and these industries.
Experts say China may be positioning to take the lead,...
...and not just in wind energy.
The country now has the largest solar power manufacturing industry,...
...with the government recently approving a plan to build the largest solar field on Earth,...
...65 square kilometers,...
...generating enough energy to light three million homes.